jean-marie le pen n'est plus couvert par
l'immunité parlementaire c'est le
parlement européen qui vient de prendre
cette décision
polémique sur les propos du chef de
l'état sur l'immigration enquête sur le
travail clandestin des immigrés dans ce
journal
pierre arpaillange se fâche
après les évasions récente des prisons
le ministre de la justice demande de
vérifier toutes les prisons l'abbé
grégoire monge et condorcet hommage et
transfert de leurs cendres demain au
panthéon en direct sur antenne 2 bonsoir
la nouvelle nous est parvenue il ya une
heure à peine le parlement européen
réuni à strasbourg a décidé de lever
l'immunité parlementaire de jean marie
le pen
monsieur le pen et député européen bien
sûr mais aussi président du groupe des
droites européennes à l'assemblée de la
cee
cette affaire c'est la suite de la
sphère d'une expression qui avait
beaucoup choqué lorsque jean marie le
pen avait parlé de monsieur durafour
crématoire
rappel des faits bernard pradines au ce
jeu de mots avaient valu à me jean marie
le pen d'être poursuivi par monsieur
arpaillange le garde des sceaux pour
injures publiques envers un mini dans un
premier temps une commission du
parlement européen avait refusé de lever
l'immunité parlementaire de monsieur le
pen expliquant qu'il était difficile de
faire la distinction une plaisanterie
est une insulte et ajoutant que le
gouvernement français cherchait
peut-être trop systématiquement des
ennuis au leader du front national ce
soir
revirement la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire de jean marie le pen a été
voté à une large majorité
après cependant un long débat passionné
nous estimons que dans ce cas
l'humanisme l'immunité parlementaire de
monsieur le pen devrait être levé car
nul même si les parlementaires ne peut
être indéfiniment au dessus de la loi
pour la procédure monsieur arpaillange a
le choix entre l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire avec juge
d'instruction témoins et cela prend du
temps
ou bien une citation directe devant le
tribunal correctionnel
après que monsieur le pen ce soit
expliqué devant la police jean-marie le
pen joint par téléphone considère que
cette décision est une manoeuvre du
gouvernement pour le faire taire
me persécuter agression selon la loi du
29 juillet 81 loi sur la presse et s'il
est condamné
monsieur le pen risque de six jours à
trois mois de prison et une amende
allant de 150 à 180 milles francs la
semaine dernière donc jean marie le pen
triomphé après les élections partielles
me jours après il le faire c'est un coup
d'arrêt mais surtout bien un coup sévère
porté à jean marie le pen pourtant
euphoriques après les résultats récents
de dreux et de marseille le président du
front national n'était plus députés
français il perd aujourd'hui son
immunité parlementaire de député
européen cela signifie d'abord qu'il
peut maintenant être poursuivi comme un
autre citoyen on vient de le voir mais
au delà c'est une défaite politique et
symbolique pour le front national à
strasbourg
une large majorité de députés pas
seulement de gauche vient en effet de
condamner fermement les outrances
verbales de jean-marie le pen
il reste maintenant à connaître les
suites judiciaires de cette affaire mais
aussi les conséquences politiques
on peut imaginer que le président du
front national tentera de modérer son
discours mais cela ne veut pas dire ce
soir que la remontée du front national
est stoppée pour autant il faut tout de
même rappeler que les excès de jean
marie le pen n'ont pas entamé les forces
du front national on l'a vu récemment
cours d'élections mais ce vote est une
première il fallait faire plus ce soir
que de simplement le signaler merci
gilles l'intervention du chef de l'état
sur antenne 2 suite c'était hier soir ce
sont surtout les propos du président
mitterrand sur l'immigration qui ont
fait réagir aujourd'hui en effet sur la
politique internationale et notamment
sur le sommet strasbourg les dirigeants
de l'opposition ont en général à prouver
les explications du chef de l'état sur
l'immigration en revanche c'est une
nouvelle polémique qui s'est engagé
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle que
monsieur mitterrand a dit hier qu'il
fallait distinguer dans les immigrés les
clandestins et les autres pour les
clandestins ils doivent être expulsés a
dit le président conformément à la loi
pour les autres il faut en revanche les
intégrer c'est sur le problème du
travail clandestin en effet que la
sphère est compliqué ce travail clan
estaing on le trouve partout ado porte
en plein coeur de paris
voici l'enquète d'isabelle stress et
elisabeth et faisait travailler une
heure ou deux ils n'attendent que cela
charger décharger les pièces de tissus
les vêtements aux sentiers place du
caire chaque jour des dizaines
d'immigrés
4 le moindre signe d'un futur employeur
ici bien sûr tout le monde dira qu'il
n'ya pas d'immigrés clandestins pas le
travail clandestin loyer via médium est
comme ça non il n'y a pas des patrons
qui travaillent qui emploie des
travailleurs clandestins dans le sentier
non
bonjour tout le monde est en forme moi
personnellement j'ai n'ai jamais entendu
parler de ce clandestin
j'ai 24 ans je suis dans ce quartier
effectivement on entend ce genre de
propos mais pour moi ce faux il semble
pourtant qu on se voile la face le
travail illégal existe bien un sentier
comme nous l'expliquent un pakistanais
employé depuis longtemps dans le
quartier
les gens travaillent illégalement dans
les magasins pour une heure ou deux on
les prend en général pour livrer des
colis pas tous les employeurs le font
bien sûr mais la moitié d'entre eux pour
faire des économies
instabilité et loi du silence ici
l'ampleur du travail clandestin est
impossible à mesurer
il est difficile aussi d'avoir des
chiffres précis en matière de travail
clandestin
mais pour les professionnels de
l'habillement le préjudice s'élèverait à
plusieurs milliards de francs
il est bien certain que cette activité
qui est notamment concentrés à paris
fait un tort considérable à la
profession selon un rapport du ministère
du travail
en 87 3600 procès verbaux ont été
dressés pour infractions au code du
travail tous secteurs confondus à côté
du textile
ce sont le bâtiment l'agriculture et
certains services comme la réparation
automobile et la restauration qui sont
les plus touchés géographiquement la
palme revient à l'ile-de-france et à la
région provence alpes côte d'azur
86% des clandestins seraient des
étrangers en situation irrégulière et
d'après l'insee toujours en 87
l'ensemble des travailleurs clandestins
auraient réalisé un chiffre d'affaires
de 62 milliards de francs l'équivalent
de celui de citroën ou de saint gobain
réaction aux propos de françois
mitterrand jacques chirac par exemple le
président du rpr a estimé que le bilan
de la présidence européenne de monsieur
mitterrand était un peu terne
les autres ont surtout parlé de
l'immigration je vous le disais pour
charles pasqua
l'intervention du chef de l'état s'était
langue de bois langue de bois pardon et
contre vérités
madame simone veil a regretté qu'une
véritable politique de l'immigration
n'est pas été explicitées quant à alain
juppé le secrétaire général du rpr pour
lui le président mitterrand rôle pour le
pen fin de citation
l'un des thèmes abordés hier a été le
vote des immigrés aux élections locales
monsieur mitterrand et pour
personnellement mais il fait il l'a dit
que les français y sont plutôt opposées
il existe des villes ou des expériences
en ce sens ont été tentées à mantes la
jolie par exemple une ville où il ya 30
% d'immigrés et bien ceux ci sont
représentés dans les commissions extra
municipales
ils ne sont pas élus mais ils
participent roland sicard françois
granier reportage
avant la démocratie municipale est une
histoire ancienne pourtant le maire a
renoncé associé directement les immigrés
à la gestion de la vie il ya une dizaine
d'années il avait bien tenté
l'expérience
une sorte de conseil municipal bis avait
été créée composée d'immigrés il avait
un rôle consultatif
mais au bout d'un an l'expérience a été
abandonnée les étrangers ne forment pas
un groupe homogène
difficile dans ces conditions de se
mettre d'accord et aujourd'hui le maire
de nantes a préféré adopter des
solutions beaucoup plus souple ma
méthode je ne peux pas considérer les
immigrés comme des gens à part lorsqu'il
y a des problèmes dans la ville ils sont
concernés qu'ils sont confirmés dans le
quartier pour des problèmes de logement
de réhabilitation d'un aménagement dans
le problème du sport pour les
répartitions des salles sportives et
cetera eh bien ils sont appelés avec les
associations classiques françaises
sportive avec les habitants du quartier
avec les associations autres non
immigrés du quartier au même titre et on
travaille ensemble
insertion et concertation résultats
malgré un taux record de 30 % d'immigrés
manque ne défraye pas la chronique ici
la mosquée est une histoire ancienne
elle a été inaugurée il y a dix ans et
dans les écoles les problèmes de voile
ont été réglées au coup par coup à
chaque fois les étrangers ont été
consultés et ils apprécient ce qui est
important c'est que
on a notre mot à dire ce qu'on pense ce
qu'on désire là c'est important et
pourquoi ça jours plus tard
ça compte pour nous parce que déjà la
municipalité quand ils discutent avec
nous et qu'on continue qu'on nous écoute
il nous met dans le même plan que les
français bien sûr monde connaît aussi la
délinquance la drogue ou une certaine
forme d'intégrisme musulmans pourtant
l'intégration semble être en bonne voie
le dialogue un fini parfait le garde des
sceaux pierre arpaillange en colère il
veut que toutes les prisons française
soit vérifiée
le ministre de la justice réagit ainsi
aux évasions spectaculaires depuis cinq
jours à lannemezan et amont et à mende
en lozère les enquêtes très précises
seront engagées
véronique gallium à lannemezan neuf
détenus avaient fait le mieux mercredi
dernier après avoir fait sauter l'accès
au mirador amendes les dvd sont tout
simplement sorti par la grande porte
dans les hautes pyrénées comme en lozère
et recherches se poursuivent des
barrages ont été établis dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche coup de filet dans un
bar près de pau de 17 détenus de
lannemezan encore en fuite sont repris
certains auraient apparaissent là
d'autres disparaissent this i am ende
dimanche matin quatre malfaiteurs
chevronnés se font la belle sans oublier
samedi soir à doué un détenu profite
d'un transfert entre l'hôpital et la
prison pour fausser compagnie aux
gardiens total 14 évadé en quatre jours
disent toujours en fuite
les syndicats pénitentiaires évoque le
sous-effectif le garde des sceaux en
appelle à plus de vigilance
nous demandons depuis longtemps la
remise en service de quartier de haute
sécurité
on la refuse justement on dit que non on
banalise tout eh bien on voit le
résultat
nous avons une volonté genève 2
d'établir des règles plus simple
d'accueillir beaucoup mieux qu'on ne l'a
fait jusqu'ici ce qu'ils ont à faire à
la justice
24 gardien pour 51 détenus à mende 131
pour 198 détenus à lannemezan les deux
prisons étaient plutôt des modèles du
genre elle accueillait tous deux des
trouilles ans au casier judiciaire bien
rempli en trois ans de 107 détenus se
sont évadés des prisons françaises selon
la chancellerie 90% aurait été repris
deuxième action des terroristes du fln
c'est en corse en moins d'un mois
la nuit dernière à 3 heures du matin
cette charge explosive ont détruit 80
appartements dans un complexe immobilier
près de calvi
l'ensemble était en fin de construction
de fin de construction pardon le flnc a
revendiqué
bruno roger-petit il signature qui ne
trompent pas quatre lettres sur un mur
flnc
ce sont donc bien les militants de l'ex
front national de libération corses qui
ont détruit la nuit dernière 40 des 120
bungalow de l'oasis un village de
vacances proche de calme dans un
communiqué authentifié le fnlc
revendique l'attentât et dénonce dans la
présence de ce village de vacances
les investissements de capitaux non
corses sur le territoire de l'île
ce n'est pas la première fois que
l'organisation 10 août s'en prend à ce
type d'objectif il y à un mois le centre
touristique de santa luca di porto diego
avait également été détruits dans les
mêmes conditions
depuis le 6 août dernier en effet le
flnc est entré en guerre contre ce
qu'ils appellent les alibis
multinationaux de l'immobilier
touristique
avis aux forces de l'ordre l'attentât de
la nuit dernière ne sera peut-être pas
le dernier du genre chronique des pays
de l'est comme tous les soirs avec
d'abord une conférence des alliés à
berlin-ouest les ambassadeurs des quatre
puissances alliées qui contrôlent berlin
se sont réunis pour discuter d'une
éventuelle évolution du statut de la
ville c'était en discussion cet
après-midi à berlin - à l'est encore
dans la journée la tchécoslovaquie qui
démantèlent physiquement son rideau de
fer la frontière avec l'autriche
et puis la bulgarie en plénum spéciale
du parti communiste on a appris en fin
d'après midi que dans ce pays encore il
y aura des élections libres
prochainement et aussi que le
rôle dirigeant du parti communiste est
abolie jacques merlino explications à la
veille de l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
session du congrès des députés
merrill gorbatchev a prévenu les
dirigeants du parti communiste de
l'union soviétique
faites vite si vous ne voulez pas perdre
le pouvoir ce qui se passe dans les pays
de l'est pourrait bien se produire
rapidement à moscou en tchécoslovaquie
c'est en route le nouveau gouvernement a
prêté serment hier il est en majorité
non communiste et l'élection du prochain
président de la république se jouera
sans doute entre eux
rassam havel 53 ans intellectuelle et
alexandre do check 71 ans l'homme qui
était à la tête du pays lors du
printemps de prague en gris le premier
ministre miss klaus name est bien avouer
que les partis d'opposition refusaient
de former un gouvernement de coalition
il a précisé que les élections
parlementaires auront lieu le 18 mars ce
seront les premières élections libres en
hongrie depuis 1947 les anciens
communistes ne se font guère d'illusions
en bulgarie le comité central du parti
et réunit aujourd'hui en plénum
extraordinaire pour étudier la situation
du pays une situation en pleine
accélération puisque hier plus de 50000
personnes ont défilé dans les rues de
sofia en demandant la démission du
dirigeant communiste en pologne enfin on
fêtait aujourd'hui le centième jour du
gouvernement mazodier ski un bilan
encore fragile premier problème vaincre
l'inflation elle est actuellement en
tendant supérieur à 1000 %
second problème un début d'agitation
sept morts dans les prisons polonaises
ce week-end et des manifestations anti
soviétique qui s'enchaînent à cracovie
à tel point qu'il a fallu démonter une
statue de lénine afin de la soustraire à
la colère populaire est en ce moment
même en allemagne de l'est une nouvelle
manifestation les psych regroupe près de
cent mille personnes
le slogan qui revient le plus souvent
est sans ambiguïté il demande que les
communistes quitte le pouvoir
sans plus attendre
la france en position d'attenté aux
comores ce mec là bas un mercenaire
d'origine française le fameux bob denard
tient ses îles de l'océan indien sous
son pouvoir le président abdallah a été
assassiné à la fin du mois dernier par
l'un des sbires de bob denard et la
situation est très tendue
le ministre français de la défense
jean-pierre chevènement a toutefois
indiqué que la france n'avait pas
l'intention d'intervenir militairement
aux comores michel mompontet ils sont
arrivés de la réunion de djibouti ou
encore de la métropole depuis trois
jours mayotte vite à l'heure de la
légion étrangère sur son sol
objectif bien sûr les îles voisines des
comores
cinq hélicoptères puma 5 transall de
transport de troupes 800 hommes dont 250
membres de commandos d'élite sur le pied
de guerre
officiellement bien sûr il ne s'agit pas
là d'un préparatifs d'intervention
militaire sur l'archipel comorien
seulement d'une éventuelle opération de
rapatriement des 1600 français y
résident les un aviso escorteur un
patrouilleur et un pétrolier
ravitailleur de la marine française
mouillé actuellement dans le port de
mayotte et serait prêt à intervenir en
quelque sorte en légitime défense
mais le spectre d'un débarquement est
bien présent tout du moins c'est ce
qu'on veut faire croire à bob denard
mais malgré les négociations entreprises
pour le faire partir en douceur malgré
la menace d'un débarquement en force
bob denard tient toujours l'archipel
comorien les médecins bientôt d'accord
avec la sécurité sociale il s'agit de la
nouvelle convention elle serait signé
très prochainement mais seulement pour
les médecins généralistes
véronique auger après huit mois de
rumeurs d'auto intoxication de
tractations entre généralistes
spécialistes et gouvernement on
s'apprête à fumer le calumet de la paix
seuls seraient concernées au départ les
médecins général première modification
principale leurs honoraires seront
revalorisées le prix de la consultation
des généralistes conventionnés
augmentera de 5 francs l'an prochain est
de 10 francs 91 deuxième modification
pendant deux ans interdiction à ceux qui
n'ont pas déjà fait de sauter du secteur
1 conventionné au secteur 2 à honoraires
libre au delà de cette période
transitoire les partenaires sociaux
devraient avoir trouvé une solution à la
fuite des médecins vers le secteur libre
chez les généralistes on respire
cette convention unique les rassure et
les conforte dans leur rôle jusqu'à
présent le médecin généraliste était en
france considéré un petit peu comme le
le médecin de proximité souvent comme le
dépanneur d'un système de santé alors
que là l'élément éminemment important
tenu sanitaire c'est que l'on va
institutionnaliser l'activité des
médecins généralistes dans le système de
choix qu'il s'agit de la médecine de
premier recours qu'il s'agit de la
prévention qu'il s'agit du suivi des
patients de la continuité des soins et
de la synthèse
les spécialistes vont maintenant établir
leur propre convention mais avec le même
objectif arrêter la croissance folle des
dépenses de 120 l'ecstasy connexion
c'est le nom que les gendarmes ont donné
au réseau de vente de drogue qu'ils ont
démantelé 22 personnes sous les verrous
c'est un retraité qui fabriquait cette
drogue qu'on appelle l'ecstasy bruno gex
pour la surnomme la pilule d'amour
l'excitation sexuelle garantie distille
la discothèque et son lieu de
prédilection
l'ecstasy est devenu populaire un
phénomène de masse surtout en angleterre
aux pays bas elle a fait son apparition
il ya quatre ans depuis elle s'est
répandue comme une traînée de poudre
mdm a c'est sa formule chimique un
dérivé de l'amphétamine
né dans les années 50 l'ecstasy est un
produit de synthèse
pendant la guerre froide la cia
l'utilisaient comme sérum de vérité
gélules ou cachait il existe des
centaines de variétés d'ecstasy sa
combinaison chimiques pouvant varier à
l'infini amsterdam gare centrale à
quelques mètres de là le quartier chaud
de la capitale drogue prostitution
c'est là qu'habite en sirène co2
inconditionnels de l'ecstasy l'effet
principal de l'usagé d'ecstasy serez
l'aide la dépendance psychologique le
fait d'avoir besoin de reprendre du
produit de ça comme ça se produit avec
tous les produits de cette série
chimique soit les amphétamines l'élu mda
qui est assez proche de l'ecstasy ou
d'autres substances et puis voir surtout
dans un premier temps des accidents dans
psychologique d état confusionnel des
étapes proches d'état psychotique et
pour il peut y avoir théoriquement des
overdoses avec ce genre de produits la
partie est difficile pour la police dans
sa lutte contre le trafic d'ecstasy
comme pour les autres drogues les
dealers vous la propose
mais ici pas question de remonter des
filières il n'y a pas de véritable gros
bonnets de l'ecstasy sa production est
très particulière vous pouvez la
fabrique et assure place dans la région
la matière première
vous vous la procurer chez n'importe
quel industriels de la pharmacie vous
pouvez le faire vous même c'est pour ça
qu'on la trouve partout il n'y a que des
productions locales en six mois une
vingtaine de producteurs ont été arrêtés
ici en hollande mais les enquêteurs le
savent bien c'est à une multitude de
laboratoires clandestins qu'ils ont à
faire
d'autres informations pour sceptre
journée de lundi a commencé par les
rumeurs sur les otages occidentaux au
liban c'est louis carzou qui commande
cette actualité l'iran demande à ses
amis au liban de libérer les otages
qu'ils détiennent
c'est ali mohamed béchard a t'il vice
ministre iranien des affaires étrangères
qui a lancé cet appel aujourd'hui dans
un quotidien de téhéran il reste
actuellement dix huit occidentaux
détenus au liban
premier accord franco soviétique dans le
domaine du nucléaire civil annoncé ce
matin par pierre delaporte présidente de
ds
l'accord porte sur la conception des
centrales nucléaires de l'an 2000 en urs
après les négociations franco hongroise
ce contrat confirme l'ouverture de la
france vers les pays de l'est en matière
d'énergie nucléaire
la vente de la vignette 90 prolongée
jusqu'au 28 décembre sans pénalité
conséquence de la grève des agents des
finances cette mesure concerne les 80
départements où la vignette est déjà en
vente pour les 11 départements où la
vente a été la plus retarder le délai
court jusqu'au 27 janvier
petite faiblesse à la bourse de paris
aujourd'hui une indice cac 40 cédait 0
24% en fin de séance une séance tout
aussi timorés pour le dollar la devise
américaine a cédé 1 centime à seafrance
04 55
et j'ajoute à tout cela les résultats du
téléthon pour l'instant plus de 256
millions de francs plus de 25 milliards
de centimes comme dirait drucker c'est
cette somme qui était promise par les
français pour les maladies génétiques
lors des 32 heures du téléthon alors
bravo à tous merci
cette somme dépasse largement les
chiffres de 87 et 88
mais sachez que vous pouvez toujours
donné pour le téléthon 89 par le minitel
d'abord 36,15 téléthon et puis sinon
vous pouvez toujours envoyer un chèque à
l'afm
le ccp s'est voulu lutter sur votre
écran 36 35
j'ai grande cérémonie demain au panthéon
françois mitterrand présidera la
cérémonie d'hommage à condorcet à l'abbé
grégoire et à mon âge
jack lang qui est ministre de la culture
et du bicentenaire prononcera leurs
loges demain entre 19h et 20h ce sera en
direct sur antenne 2 philippe dumez et
jean-claude d'arrigo nous rafraîchir la
mémoire sur ses erreurs 1789
grégoire un petit curé lorrain est nommé
député aux états généraux
il est prêtre est néanmoins les idées
républicaines le séduisent il va donc
jouer la carte de la révolution en
essayant de concilier sa conscience de
chrétiens et sa conception de la
démocratie
nommé par le peuple et non plus par le
pape évêque de blois
il partage son temps entre son évêché et
la tribune de l'assemblée au pire moment
de la terreur il y siège courageusement
protestant notamment contre les lois
anti religieuse et la déprécarisation du
clergé et promouvant les droits de
l'homme et du citoyen il aura une action
décisive en faveur des protestants des
juifs et des esclaves noirs
le consulat lempire la restauration le
marginalise rond l'église de l'époque
que lui refusera les derniers sacrements
il demeurera fidèle à ses convictions
grégoire un personnage controversé
encore aujourd'hui parmi les catholiques
aucun évêque ne sera présent en
transfert de ses cendres nous voudrons
pas l'adhésion de la république à
l'honor l'un de ses fils par te laisses
tes mots qu'il a de grandes qualités
très bien
nous ne bouderons pas mais supposer que
nous y soyons
de manière officielle commence la route
ils interprétèrent ou bien nous
cautionnons ce qui est finalement une
initiative dont l'ambiguïté
ils ne peuvent pas ne pas apparaître aux
yeux de beaucoup nous cautionnons une
certaine ambiguïté et si nous nous
abstenons nous boude on s'est mis lundi
l'eau autres personnages célèbres de la
révolution française
gaspard monge compte de pellehue croquer
ici par l'un de ses élèves pendant un
cours c'est le portrait le plus
authentique de ce mathématicien créateur
de la géométrie descriptive éminents
professeurs et partisans enthousiastes
de la révolution il fut l'un des
fondateurs de l'école polytechnique
c'est incontestablement monge qui donne
à l'impulsion scientifique à cette
brillante écoles ou les mathématiques et
la physique ont toujours une place de
choix militarisée en 1804 l'école
polytechnique a aussi su former de
grands politiciens et c'est peut-être
encore à gaspard monge qu'elle le doit
il accompagne est en effet toujours
napoléon et s'étaient révélés souvent
bon négociateur
le marquis de condorcet philosophe et
homme politique créa sous la convention
un plan d'organisation de l'instruction
mais même aux abords d'un lycée qui
porte son nom à paris on ne le connais
guère
monsieur qui messieurs condorcet
l art et condorcet de monsieur couderc
c'est non est ce que vous connaissez
monsieur condorcet oui très bien si
c'était un philosophe et en même temps
un mathématicien de l'appeler les
encyclopédistes et voilà l'expédition
300 articles qui arrive en ce moment
même au pôle sud
six hommes dont le docteur jean louis
etienne nous vous en avons déjà parlé
six hommes de six pays différents entre
entreprises cet exploit traverser
l'antarctique
jean ma mère fait le point sur leur
progression dimanche soir lors du
dernier arrêt et par une température de
moins 27 degrés l'expédition espérait
atteindre le pôle sud lundi dans la
journée une dernière tempête de neige a
de nouveau ralenti leur progression ils
n'ont pu effectuer qu'une marche de 39
km un peu moins que les 43 de la veille
dans une heure maintenant ils vont
atteindre le pôle sud et rejoint d'une
grande base américaine dite d'homs et
les communications sont extrêmement
difficile à établir en raison de
l'éloignement de leurs bases arrières de
puntarenas seule la balise argos
renseigne sur leur position en raison du
retard pris dizaine de jours
l'expédition ne restera que 48 heures et
si elle peut être logé à la base
américaine
elle doit profiter de la période d'été
de son temps relativement plus clément
pour continuer la marche et atteindre
miri le but de l'expédition aux dates
prévues
il reste encore à jean louis etienne et
ses camarades a effectué une marche de
trois mille kilomètres autant que ce
qu'il dit est déjà de parcourir
il y à des pronostics ce pirate brest
pour le tiercé de demain nous allons les
voir le tiercé secours à vincennes c'est
donc du trot qui arrêtent nous propose
de jouer le 18 le 16 le 11 las le 14 le
12 le 15 et le 3 la météo s'est tout de
suite mais je sais pas avec qui je
l'espère que peut être c'est cabrol je
sais enfin la branche alors notre bouche
c'est pas envie ce sera la surprise
les rendez vous de ce soir vers 22h25
comment ça va
c'est l'excellente émission médicale
d'henri sannier consacré ce soir la
migraine nous sommes nombreux à en
souffrir et puis vers 23h15 dernières
éditions christian mary mono bonne
soirée sur antenne 2 à demain 20 heures
tout de suite la météo surprise